Korona virus is spreading and economies
all over the world are grinding to a
halt we will examine whether we're all
going to die before we go broke then new
polling shows a big boost to Bernie
Estanza of winning the Democratic
nomination freshman representative Ilhan
Omar de Mnet's she's an American and
Harvey Weinstein is headed for the clink
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show we
have a lot to get to today so many
things out there are trying to kill you
one big threat that's out there that is
not as physical as it is informational
would be threats to your data did you
know that your internet service provider
say Comcast or Verizon maybe they know
every single website that you visit
every single one even the ones on the
incognito window I'm talking of course
of daily wire comm what's worse is they
can sell this information to ad
companies and tech giant's who will then
use your data to target you expressvpn
puts a stop to this it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that your online
activity cannot be seen by anyone
expressvpn works on everything phones
laptops even routers so that everyone
who shares your Wi-Fi can still be
protected even if they don't have
expressvpn I have one of their routers
it's absolutely fabulous very important
to protect your data so if you're like
me and you believe that your online
activity is your business no one else's
secure yourself by visiting expressvpn
comm slash Michael today use my link
expr ESS VPN dot-com slash Michael and
you can get an extra three months for
free
that's expressvpn comm slash Michael so
much to get to so we will get to all of
it the coronavirus the corona virus
poses a major threat to the whole world
but that threat is not exactly the kind
of threat you think it is
the threat is mostly political and
economical it's actually not as much
biological there is a ton of myth
information going around in background
virus so let's just look at the numbers
very quickly so you can see where the
threat really lies so far during the
outbreak of this virus 2600 people have
died it started in the city of Wuhan in
China
Wuhan has a population of 11 million
people
Wuhan is in hebei province the brothel
Asian net province is 58 and a half
million people so that's basically the
population of Italy Italy by the way
acto has one of the worst death tolls
anywhere from coronavirus and that death
toll is now at five confirmed deaths
coronavirus has also hit Iran Iran has
12 confirmed deaths obviously very sad
when anybody dies but to put that in
perspective we're also in flu season
right during this flu season alone do
you know how many people have died from
the flu 14,000 people so far during just
this flu season five times as many
people have died from the flu the
regular old flu as have died from corona
virus last flu season when everything
was said and done over 61 thousand
people died now what is the death rate
for the flu the death rate for the flu
is 0.1% so if you're healthy and you get
the flu most likely gonna be totally
fine if you're very very young or very
old then it can be dangerous 0.1% death
rate in mainland China the death rate
for coronavirus is in some provinces
about 0.4% so higher but still much less
than 1% even in Hubei Province right the
epicenter of coronavirus the death rate
has peaked at two point nine percent so
that's mainland China the province where
it's happening right the city where it's
happening if you control for America's
vastly superior public health
infrastructure the death rate for
coronavirus is not dramatically higher
than the death rate for the flu so the
unique threat that coronavirus poses
right now not really to our health as
much I mean people are monitoring it but
the real threat seems to be to the
economy it is tanking the world economy
right now China's economy was already on
the fritz all right it was already at
the lowest level of growth that we've
seen since 1990 so 30 years as a result
of this coronavirus the country has more
or less ground to a halt that's also
true in Italy so Italy right now the
city of Milan which drives the whole
Italian economy has ground to a halt
Milan's more or less on lockdown frankly
I am of Italian descent I've spent some
time in Italy
I think the Italians just look for any
excuse to stop working but regardless
the economic effect is the same you're
seeing a slowdown this is happening all
around the world yesterday the Dow Jones
dropped a thousand points because of
coronavirus fears maybe there's a little
pricing in there of fears about Bernie
Sanders they don't want the leading
world economy to have a socialist
president but I think probably a lot of
its traceable to coronavirus this was
the third worst point drop in history of
the Dow Jones so this is why President
Trump is downplaying coronavirus he
tweeted out yesterday quote the
coronavirus is very much under control
in the USA we are in contact with
everyone and all relevant countries CDC
and world health have been working hard
and very smart
stock markets starting to look very good
to me now he's obviously trying to boost
confidence here I don't know if he
really thinks the stock market's looking
good because it was the third worst
point drop in history nevertheless
President Trump understands the real
threat here is economic if the economy
tanks that is pretty much the only way
that Trump loses this presidential
election okay things are looking very
good right now for president Trump
you've got this wacko socialist who is
double and triple Adele Castro running
away with the Democratic nomination
we'll get to that in just a little bit
you've got the so-called moderate can't
even say his own name on the campaign
trail Joe Biden you've got the other
moderate Peabody jej is actually a huge
radical who drags nine year old boys on
stage at his campaign events to come out
as homosexual pretty pretty radical
whose father was the head of the
International Gramsci Society so Trump
is looking great unless the economy
tanks how on earth could the economy
tape record low unemployment record high
stock markets great growth the way it
could tank is if you have this totally
unpredictable virus that's taking over
the whole world is that why the media
are playing up coronavirus so much it's
a good question because we know the
death rate is relatively low we know
relatively few people have been affected
by it and yet the media are treating
this as though it's the next bubonic
plague that's going to kill all of us
some prominent people in the media have
been hoping for a recession and they've
been hoping for a recession because even
though it's gonna hurt a lot of people
the recession will reduce the chances
that President Trump gets reelected
that's not some right-wing conspiracy
theory we saw this on Bill Maher's show
just a few months ago he's doing I guess
they're just gonna have to keep touching
this hot stuff I'm not wishing for a
recession but if the farmers want to
keep touching well you should wish for a
recession because that will definitely
get him unelected okay well you don't
really I really do we have survived many
recessions we can't survive another
Donald Trump it's like lower middle
the ballot box in the intellectual
marketplace to help you look at least
Bill Maher tells you what he thinks
right and I think a lot of other people
in the media feel exactly the same way
okay now I don't think that liberals
invented coronavirus I don't think they
went to like the lip Lib lab and
developed this bio weapon so that they
could get rid of Donald Trump however I
don't think it came from bats either
remember the initial story with
coronavirus is some people in wuhan ate
some bat soup and I was dumb and now one
of the bats head coronavirus and now
everybody's sick that story is starting
to break down there is now a lot of
evidence that the corona virus was
cooked up as potentially a biological
weapon in a Chinese government lab the
evidence of this is that the Chinese
Ministry of Science and Technology just
released a new directive titled quote
instructions on strengthening
biosecurity management in microbiology
labs that handle advanced viruses like
the novel coronavirus you say well how
many these labs do you have floating
around China that or just happen to be
handling these radical viruses and the
answer is they have one and that one lab
happens to be in Wuhan that's a lot of a
coincidence so it may be the case that
China the Chinese government was cooking
up this new biological weapon it got out
somehow it's now affecting their own
population it's now spreading around the
world that is pretty bad news we've got
more bad news for the economy but I do
want to remind you if you were a Daily
wire subscriber if you're a member and
you have the the app or you're on the
website right now write in your
questions and we're going to be taking a
few live questions during the show
you're pressing deepest most burning
question this year that you've got we
will do our best to answer them on top
of the corona virus we've got more bad
news for the economy namely Bernie
Sanders is freaking killing it well he's
gonna freaking kill the economy but he's
also freaking killing it in the
Democratic primary race Bernie Sanders
just took a
major boost to his campaign Bernie has
taken the lead among black Democratic
primary voters nationally huge news
we've been talking about this for months
now Bernie had the momentum but Bernie's
base has always been pretty narrow he's
always had a very white very far left
base and so he was gonna struggle in
states like say South Carolina Joe
Biden's only argument for electing him
or nominating him this year was that
he's the only guy who can win black
votes well now Bernie Sanders is doing
better among black voters than Joe Biden
is this is according to a morning
consult poll it was just released
yesterday nationally Bernie Sanders is
at 32% among black Democratic primary
voters Bloomberg is in second place with
19 percent Biden is all the way down in
third at 18 percent followed by Budaj
and Warren who both have 11% and then
everybody else comes after that evidence
of our thesis yesterday which is that a
classic blunder in politics is people
think they can win by losing they think
they can skip Iowa New Hampshire and
South Carolina and Nevada but you know
they're gonna come back afterward they
can lose they can lose they can lose now
Mike Bloomberg is technically skipping
those elections he's not on the ballot
but he's spending heavy he is on the
airwaves in those states as though he is
running and so because he's got a kind
of unique cannon as he came in so late
he's being considered among the
candidates even though he's not really
on the ballot Joe Biden the same cannot
be said Joe Biden is not running
competitively there his money is running
out he is not showing up to these places
as strongly as he used to be and he's
losing he's been on the ballot in Iowa
New Hampshire and he keeps losing so all
of a sudden Joe Biden and drops down to
third you've got black voters in these
states saying gosh Joe Biden was the
number one guy he can't win any state
that he's been on the ballot
I guess our best shot is Bernie who has
been winning and our second best shot is
Mike Bloomberg who's not even on the
ballot
but he's spending a lot of money looks
like he's running to win it and Joe
Biden is reacting in exactly the way you
would expect
he is sputtering and stammering and
recently on the campaign trail just
yesterday he forgot what office he's
running for you're the ones that sent
Barack Obama the presidency and I have a
simple proposition here I'm here to ask
you for your help
where I come from you don't get far
unless you ask my name is Joe Biden I'm
a Democratic candidate for the United
States Senate look me over if you're
like we see help out if not both the
other by give me a look though okay
that's all I've really got to say to you
what what just happened
forget what he just said what is what is
he even doing what's firing in his his
head Joe Biden has not been in the
Senate for 12 years a dozen years
remember he was in the Senate and was
the vice president after Obama won in
2008 then he did nothing for 3-4 years
now he's running for president again but
he did run for Senate for a very long
time he first ran for sent in the 70s
and he was there all the way through a
knee to Hill he was the Judiciary
Chairman during an ADA held and he was
there all the way through 2008 so he's I
think he's just reverting back to his
default mode which is hi I'm Joe Biden
I'm a total glad-handing politician who
doesn't stand for anything and I'm
running for the State of Delaware I'm
running for the Senate vote for me even
the way he closes it was like a typical
caricature of a politician from 20 30
years ago
I'm Joe Biden I'm asking for your vote
if you don't like me vote for the other
Biden I get it if you don't like me you
should still vote for me because my name
will be on the ballot just give me a
look all right I'm running for Senate
you don't even know what you're running
for so probably very few people are
going to vote for you his campaign I
think knows that this is falling apart
not just because he doesn't know how to
speak on the campaign trail also because
his whole strategy was predicated on
crushing it in South Carolina and now it
looks like he's headed for not only a
weak performance I
there's a chance he still wins but he's
neck-and-neck with Bernie right now
there's actually a chance he loses South
Carolina and Joe Biden said from the
very beginning he said South Carolina is
my firewall by the way when you're a
candidate running for president and you
say that a state far from now is your
firewall that is evidence of a weak
campaign that's evidence that you think
you're gonna do badly in the earliest
states but you're gonna come back in the
later early state and that's simply not
not what's happening here so he said it
was the firewall he's now collapsing
he's asked about this on CBS News and
Joe Biden immediately denies that he
ever called South Carolina the firewall
South Carolina though was your firewall
you said it my firewall I've never seen
pain has that your fax no I said I'm
gonna do well there and I'll do well
there and I'll do well be on there as
well I never said it was my firewall let
me quote Joe Biden
about a month ago I think I'll do well
in Nevada and I think I have a real
firewall in South Carolina say direct
quote that he gave to the press less
than a month ago and then we go into the
Super Tuesday states that I have a
significant number of minorities and
african-americans I think I have a real
firewall in South Carolina I never said
I have a firewall yeah I said look I
said I maybe I do well there but come on
you said I have a firewall no now Joe
doesn't remember what he said doesn't
remember what office he's running for it
doesn't remember what office he's he's
not going to win it's I think he's
starting to learn that he's starting to
remember that part he's absolutely
collapsing and so the question is how on
earth can the Democrats beat Trump if
Bernie is the nominee that is you've got
a radical cannon out of there so
presumably you're gonna have to balance
that out with some kind of moderate
however the new chatter among the
left-wing
pundit class is that they're not going
to go for some kind of moderate they're
actually going to go for the next most
radical candidate that Bernie Sanders
might nominate Elizabeth Warren so
there's a poll here from Zogby analytics
their analyst Jonathan Zogby
just reported that the sanders war in a
ticket
currently beats president Trump and Mike
Pence by 48 to 45% Sanders Warren could
you imagine more of a nightmare
Sanders Warren it would be terrible
because Bernie Sanders is pretty old so
there's actually a chance that you got a
president worn by the back door
this this guy Zogby believes that this
is a easy easy way to beat President
Trump no way no chance Elizabeth Warren
is horribly unlikable the more people
see Warren the less people like her
remember she was doing very very well
early on when she wasn't out there as
much and then she did all those stupid
social media videos then she came out
with her health care plan and she tanked
the more people see her the less they
like her VP picks usually don't matter
people really just vote on the president
however here it actually could hurt
Bernie because he just actually had a
heart attack on the campaign trail and
he's now refusing to release his medical
records so who knows how the guide
sticker is doing who knows how long he's
going to be with us hopefully for a very
long time but still we don't know about
the guy's health everything we do know
doesn't look good so you've got a
serious chance that this vice-president
becomes president and Elizabeth Warren
is simply awful that it's not even a
like a sexist thing everyone says
whenever you criticize him his worn it's
sexist women like her least of all she
doesn't ball very well among women
Bernie Sanders at least he is honest
right he's terrible and he's dangerous
but he's honest we'll get to that in a
second because he's doubling and
tripling down on his support of Fidel
Castro and other communist thugs but
he's not the only Democrat to do that
we'll get to that in a second first a
question from the audience from a I'm in
a Super Tuesday State should I attend
the GOP primary and show my support for
the president or should I vote Bernie in
the Democratic primary and sabotage the
left very very tricky question
Trump is going to win the primary I
don't think you need to worry about that
if some states are closed primaries so
you can only vote for the party that
you're registered in which seems to me
to make sense some states are open
primaries so a Republican can vote in
the Democratic primary and vice-versa my
bet is on
Bernie okay I think conservatives should
want Bernie to be the nominee I think he
does have the least chance of being
elected in November I'm not saying he
has no chance I don't want to get cocky
here there is if this is a risky bet
because if we take this risk and we lose
all of a sudden you've got a communist
president that's at least a very strong
socialist president and that's pretty
scary however my other theory is that
Bernie Sanders is pretty much just as
radical as the other Democrats actually
some Democrats are even more radical
than Bernie it's just that Bernie is
more honest about it so for me I'm here
to be entertained I'm here for an honest
vote and I want to sabotage the left so
look if you made it into the Democratic
primary you voted for Bernie and we've
got the battle that America deserves
Trump vs. Bernie you know there are
worse things in the world bernie is
honest okay and I like the honest fight
because I think we win the honest fight
Bernie you know he he said he liked veal
Castro then they asked him about this on
60 minutes he said he really likes Fidel
Castro then they keep asking about it he
keeps defending Fidel Castro this line
of attack is not totally fair to Bernie
okay cuz bernie is just saying what
other Democrats have said he's just
saying it more honestly and more
forcefully even Barack Obama not that
long ago just a few years ago was
defending Fidel Castro with the same
talking points that Bernie Sanders used
oh they have good health care in Cuba oh
they have good literacy programs in Cuba
if you just read a transcript of what
Barack Obama said about Castro and what
Bernie Sanders said you wouldn't be able
to tell them apart I said this to
President Castro in Cuba
I said look you've made great progress
in educating young people every child in
Cuba
it's a basic education that's that's a
huge improvement from where it was
medical care no the the life expectancy
of Cubans is equivalent to the United
States despite it being a very poor
country because they have access to
health care that's a huge achievement
they should be congratulated but you
drive around Havana this economy is not
working so as usual
Barack Obama totally misrepresenting
things not surprising at all
but he is saying the same thing as
Bernie they're both wrong because first
of all Cuba cooks the books on their
health care and part of the reason that
they have a relatively high life
expectancy is because they do everything
they can to prevent infant mortality to
make sure that that number looks pretty
good I've been around to Vanna with
Cubans they've pointed to that great
Havana hospital they say there is the
Havana Hospital Universal anybody can go
into it of course there's no medicine
when you go in you got to bring your own
medicine you got to bring your own
toilet paper there's a direct quotes
from people in Havana but yeah anybody
can go in there how great right
still Barak Obama says the same thing
how come we don't give him as much guff
about it it's Bernie Sanders because
Barack Obama was a little slicker he was
a little oilier I like the honest battle
it's not just Barack Obama either here's
what the media were saying about Fidel
Castro when he died just a few years ago
declared socialist he dramatically
improved health care and literacy I
think good he will be revered as someone
who brought education and social
services and medical care to all of his
people well Fidel Castro was considered
even to this day the George Washington
of his country there is no doubt that he
is considered here a revolutionary hero
not only in Cuba but in many places
around the world and also for his
defiance of the United States you know
that's the media for you that's by the
way that last part isn't true either the
people in Cuba despised for the Al
Castro every single person that I talked
to but the whole left the whole
Democratic part
has been trending this way for a very
long time they've been trending hard
left and now they're just being more
honest about it
left-wing candidates for the last
hundred years would hide the fact that
they were socialists we all kind of
suspected they were deep down socialists
but they would hide it they would
protest they would say how dare you how
offensive that you would call me a
socialist it was considered a really
offensive thing a real insult the same
thing with atheism they would say they
would if you called someone an atheist
they'd say how dare you and most of them
are atheists but they would say no you
couldn't possibly call me that that's
when it was considered socially
unacceptable to be an atheist in a
socialist now it's socially preferable
and so now they're a little bit more
open about it you know when you think
about how Joe McCarthy is is taught in
schools people say Joe McCarthy was so
terrible he's so crossed the line he had
no dignity he had no shame because he
accused people of being socialists and
very often they were socialists and we
caught many socialists working in the
government now you've got people
bragging about it so if it's okay to be
a socialist why was why was it so
terrible when Joe McCarthy would accuse
people of that now they're admitting it
now they're even admitting their
unamerican Asst until yesterday if I
called Ilhan Omar that squad member
freshman representative if I called her
on American I would be pilloried as
racist xenophobic bigoted hateful
president Trump implied that she was not
American Way he sent out that tweet he
said you should go back to your
countries people went after him before
they went they were so upset that he
would say this to somebody like Ilhan
Omar well it turns out that he was right
by her own admission Ilhan Omar
yesterday tweeted out
I am hijab II Muslim black foreign-born
refugee Somali easily trigger late
triggering conservatives right wing
bloggers anti-muslim bigots tinfoil
conspiracy theorists birthers pay me
money to bash Muslim fraudsters Pro
Occupy
herbs in every single xenophobe since
2016 it's a long list notice anything
missing on that list I am a job' Muslim
black four and more in refugees Somali
she never says she's American she
doesn't consider herself American it's
not even that she doesn't mention
nations on that list she does Somali she
considers herself Somali but not
American so when people say go back to
your country that's considered bigoted
except it's by her own admission that
her country is Somali not American that
is radical stuff if you ever question
somebody's patriotism that was
considered off the table right but what
about when the cabinet's themselves are
questioning their own patriotism if you
called someone a socialist off the table
what if the candidates themselves are
calling them themself socialists I
prefer that battle I prefer that honest
right because that Americans have an
honest choice we have a question come in
from a listener from KC what are the
odds
Ilhan Omar is Bernie's VP choice
probably a step too far I think it's a
little low I think she's over 35 so
she's constitutionally allowed to do it
I bet that's a little over the line for
the Democratic Party I don't think
they're gonna let them get two total
radicals out there I think the most
radical you're gonna be allowed to get
is somebody like Elizabeth Warren who
obviously checks the boxes right she's
got some left-wing credentials she's a
woman and she's at least one 1024 the
Native American so she checks the
intersectionality boxes as well
Ilhan Omar just has too many legal
questions surrounding her especially the
suggestion that seems very likely that
she married her brother for for
immigration purposes you know I know
that the Democrats have never been the
party of Family Values but if you start
promoting people who marry their own
brothers well and maybe that's the way
that they can recover family values I
guess in a certain sense that's the most
family value you can have I still don't
think it would play well in Peoria so I
think luckily we have avoided that
although
frankly we live in the age of Trump we
live in the age of Bernie soaring to the
nomination
anything can happen we've got a lot more
to get to we gotta get to Harvey
Weinstein which we will in just one
second but I want to bring your
attention to a possibly overlooked but
highly valued daily wire membership tear
and that's the readers pass a readers
pass gets you the articles ad-free
including Ben's op eds
which are exclusive for daily wire
Members Only you also get access to our
mobile app to read all of our stories
and receive push notifications for
breaking news and special content which
is perfect when you want to stay up to
date on the go how much does this cost
you you're so lucky that membership tier
only costs $3 a month but if you were
still on the fence listen to this
special offer right now we're offering a
one-month deal for 99 cents that's a
mobile ad free access to all of the
daily wired news exclusive iPads and Ben
Shapiro and breaking news and updates on
our mobile app all for the low price of
$1 so go check it out you will not be
disappointed daily wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
the trial of the century Harvey
Weinstein
will he be found guilty for leading the
me to crimes of Hollywood or will he
walk Harvey Weinstein was found guilty a
little bit he wasn't found guilty in all
of his counts he was found guilty on a
couple of them he's looking at five to
twenty nine years in prison so at the
long end this could be a life sentence
for Harvey the Harvey Weinstein verdict
matters not just because what it says a
better legal system but what it says
about the relationship of our legal
system to our culture that's the part
that nobody's talking about but that's
actually the only really interesting
part of the case so the jury took five
days to deliberate and they found
Weinstein was guilty of third-degree
rape and criminal sexual act but the
jury acquitted Weinstein on the three
other counts which included the most
serious counts predatory sexual assault
so they got him on the lower end they
didn't get him on the higher end this
was actually a somewhat controversial
case I know that our v Weinstein is just
an absolute monster who in the light of
perfect moral justice would be put down
like Old Yeller but in in terms of the
legal aspect of it it was a little bit
controversial
why because Weinstein allegedly raped
these women were assaulted them or abuse
them but he had a relationship with them
after the assaults cease we would see
these emails and messages between them
that were very nice between both of them
the most prominent incidents that we saw
took place not in a dark alleyway they
took place in Harvey Weinstein's hotel
rooms and they would happen over a years
and and the women would keep coming back
so there was a real question over
whether or not Harvey Weinstein would
get off because he'd say look I've had
relationships of these women for years
if if I raped them why did they keep
visiting me and being nice to me and
going to my hotel room when the verdict
was read if you saw it in the courtroom
Weinstein looked shocked he looked he
genuinely couldn't believe it he was
muttering to his lawyers I'm innocent
I'm innocent how can this happen in
America the actual the funniest moment
of the whole trial
is wet that Harvey Weinstein was so
shocked when the verdict was read that
when he walked out of the courtroom he
forgot to take his walker so for the
whole trial he's been pretending he's
really old and decrepit and I'm
handicapped so he would use this Walker
and he could barely walk up the stairs
and then when the verdict was read he
was found guilty he's like alright well
I guess I don't need that walker anymore
doo doo doo doo that he just walked
right out there obviously Harvey
Weinstein is a sicko and should be kept
very far away from polite society for
many the question remained unclear as to
whether he committed the crimes that he
was being accused of right took that
took the jury five days and they only
got him on the two lower counts the the
aspect that matters here is less the
legal aspect more the cultural aspect
Harvey Weinstein had to be punished okay
Harvey Weinstein regardless of what the
jury found regardless of any aspect here
Harvey had to be punished it was far
from clear that he violated the law of
the land many analysts thought he'd be
acquitted but it was very clear that
Harvey violated the moral law and our
culture is extremely permissive when it
comes to that sort of thing right we
live in a permissive culture where we
say oh if it doesn't obviously hurt
anybody else it's okay you could do
whatever you want
you've got your personal autonomy you
own your body do whatever you like but
justice must be served and so even if
Weinstein didn't commit these specific
crimes that he was accused of he was
going to be punished you see this from
the perspective of rights all the time
in politics right the Constitution
affords us lots of different rights the
Constitution also is built for a moral
and religious people that's according to
John Adams right the Constitution's not
fit for people who are not moral and
religious so as moral and religious
rigidity has fallen away often through a
concerted effort in our culture the
effect of that has not been more freedom
that's what they promised us in the 60s
right they said look we've got a very
pervasive legal system and we've got
this rigid morality so just get rid of
your moral discipline and then you'll be
very free final
you'll be in control of yourself
paradoxically though the effect of that
has been less freedom as people have
become less morally disciplined the
government has stepped in to discipline
them the reason for that is that order
must be preserved so as a result we lose
our personal discipline we lose our
local and our family discipline The
effect of that is endless regulations
new speech codes now an ever changing
sexual ethic that you see at workplaces
and campuses it's because societies need
order so either we could discipline
ourselves or we will have discipline
imposed from above either
Harvey Weinstein can act like a
civilized human being or he's going to
go to the clink and that doesn't matter
how well his lawyers can argue that he
did not violate the law
speaking of sexual ethics now this is
this left-wing outlet they post all
these little videos all over social
media they have a new cause they're
following Joaquin Phoenix's speech
recently where he called to end the
terrible awful cruelty of drinking milk
right it's all about animal rights now
this has come out with one it talks
about how fish actually on some level
can feel pain and that's why it's so
unthinkable that we should ever pick
them up with our little hooks and eat
them here's now this you probably don't
spend a lot of time thinking about fish
and when you do it's likely in the
context of dinner humans don't relate
very easily to fish there's so different
promise they might as well be aliens
it's hard for us to attribute thoughts
emotions or any kind of inner life to
them for many of us they might as well
be plants or furniture this is a big
problem for fish because our being
unable to relate to these creatures as
live conscious beings means that many of
us can't even conceive of them having
the most basic element of sense
the ability to feel pain so we treat
them as if they didn't but fish do feel
pain scientists have demonstrated this
decisively fish have the same pain
receptors as humans do and they act just
like any animal would when those
receptors are activated the
obliviousness is simply shocking take
the exact same video the same script and
replace fish with babies you know we
can't really relate to unborn babies we
can we think they're different than us
but actually they are a lot more like us
than you think uh more babies are
definitely a lot more like us than fish
or unborn babies actually can feel pain
by at least as early as 20 weeks and in
some senses as early as seven weeks
maybe even earlier and that's why we
need to start thinking of unborn babies
more like humans which is what they
obviously are it's such a bizarre
characteristic of the left that they
care so much for the little delta smelt
for the little fish for the milk but
they don't care that much for people you
know they always care so much for
humanity but they don't care all that
much for actual humans but I think
animal rights is an interesting angle to
talk about this issue of abortion
because the more and more we're learning
about the brain and the more we're
learning about sentience and
consciousness the more we can apply that
to human beings as well in the short
term what that means is you should never
take seriously these left-wing arguments
about animal rights if those people are
not also pro-life you've got you should
have I don't think that being pro-life
means that you have to become a vegan
I've far from that but certainly it is
the case that if you are a vegan you
have to be pro-life because the because
the kind of ethics bioethics that
surround veganism or so much more narrow
that you've absolutely got to apply that
there's so much more rigid but you've
absolutely got to apply that to human
beings because of
it looks ridiculous think about how
ridiculous you have to be to shed tears
like Joaquin Phoenix over the milk or to
shed tears over a fish which by the way
the science is very inconclusive that
fish can feel any sort of pain but let's
let's even say that it's true think
about how crazy and absurd you've gotta
look to shed tears over a little
flounder but to be perfectly fine just
chopping up a baby doesn't make a whole
lot of sense we've got to get to the
dumbest article on the internet today
this is care of the sea or this is about
the CIA care of the New York Times and
it this is so funny I mean this is
really just the leftist tears article of
the day the left is now defending the
CIA for the vast majority of the history
of the CIA the left has been calling for
it to be abolished now President Trump
is in charge and he's appointed a new
acting director of national intelligence
so a new acting top spy who is a very
impressive person Richard Grinnell he
was the ambassador to Germany in long a
serving spokesman at the UN he's got a
great record and there's been some
suggestion that Grinnell is going to
weed out some bad actors in the
intelligence community the left is
furious here it is from Jane Harman in
the New York Times she is a demo
Democratic congressman said I helped
create the nation's top spy job it's
about to be destroyed there's a lot of
blah blah blah then it gets to moneyline
well our intelligence community is the
most impressive in the world we can't
see and know everything a purge of our
best and brightest intelligence officers
will signal to them that new management
is coming and current relationships
aren't useful any longer allied services
also won't trust us if our own officers
face constant pressure to politicize
intelligence a so called house clear and
could damage our intelligence abilities
for at least degeneration recruitment
and retention will of course plummet and
those officers and analysts left won't
have the mentorship or the experience to
ensure our assessments are based on
truth
Jane Harman a Democrat representing
California in the Congress where to
begin the issue of politicizing
intelligence is crazy the intelligence
apparatus serves in our political system
it's intrinsically politicized but what
she's really saying is we should not
allow the people who governed themselves
who elect our representatives to have
any say over the intelligence apparatus
just saying the intelligence apparatus
the deep state were part of it should
operate without any accountability to
the people whatsoever because we might
miss out on some clues if we have any
oversight whatsoever
now to be clear there's no evidence that
Richard Grinnell or Donald Trump or
anybody else is gonna gut the
intelligence apparatus they're just
gonna fire some bad guys if the guys are
shown to be bad and we've seen that
there have been some shenanigans up in
the intelligence community in recent
years that's all
and even the suggestion that they would
fire the worst employees the most
corrupt employees that creates all this
pushback this is the deep state this is
the what the Democrats want you know
there is such an irony here because the
Democrats say that they want this sort
of democratic ideal where the majority
rules and we've got power to the people
but in practice that's not what they
want in practice what they want to do is
take rights away from people and when
they get into power install a bunch of
technocratic experts who know how to run
your life better than you know how to
run your life and who are sitting on
panels and boards and agencies that have
no accountability whatsoever that's the
democratic ideal and if the left wins
this election you're going to see that
hardens you're gonna see it harder to
take away the fact that now the
intelligence community which is not that
old
it's an invention of the last hundred
years that we can't even fire bad people
within it and that when you try to do it
even the left which is pretended for
years that they hate the intelligence
community are the ones defending them
that tells you that Ronald Reagan was
right when he said that a federal job a
federal agency is the nearest thing to
eternal life on earth we've got to be
very very care
about that because if the left wins in
this year's elections you're going to
see that Hardin it's gonna be even more
difficult to fire those bad people last
question before we go from TC what who
is in that picture on the shelf some
bearded guy you know I have absolutely
no idea who that is it seems like so
long ago I think I know that person but
I don't can't quite place him that does
bring us though to a quick thank you
that I have to make because today is our
500th episode which is an absolutely
shocking number mostly shocking to Ben
who was hoping that he would be able to
can us somewhere around episode 12 but
it's also shocking to me and I just want
to take a moment to thank everyone for
listening the show has grown an order of
magnitude and many multiples in size
since our early episodes and it is
because of all of you who tuned in and
posted around the internet and sent it
around to your friends when we started I
was but a wee blank book author and
thanks to all of you who have listened
in we've been able to launch so many new
projects the Yap campus tours three
seasons of another Kingdom the book club
show at Prager U and obviously most
recently verdict with Ted Cruz which
incredibly rose to become the number one
podcast on the charts for two weeks and
I'm actually flying out this afternoon
to DC to start filming that again the
senator and I are gonna be doing a live
show at CPAC this year so if you're in
Washington I hope you will come out and
if I don't see you there
then I'll look forward to meeting you
around the country on the Yap tour which
is gonna kick off in about a week or so
and if I miss you there too where are
you where do you live I will at least
look forward to hearing from you in the
mailbag so get those questions and the
mailbag will be on Thursday thank you
again for these first 500 episodes and I
look forward to 500 more I'm Michael
Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]